[Music]
you are not afraid to admit to some
peculiarities in your private life and
we'll get to them right now
whoa no one's oh yes we are you were
arrested in 1974 for deciding no you had
to collect some strange things you
collect toilet paper do you not only
very particular toilet boat Oh
normal I had Her Majesty the Queen's
toilet poo I went to Buckingham Palace
for Prince Charles at 50th birthday
party and I thought yeah When in Rome so
I went in Rome feel the toilet
I've got Simon Cowell's which is which
is black wait did Santa kill has told me
that he has black toilet everything's
black so you go into his restroom and
the toilet papers play all the towels
are black and they're all monogrammed
with SC in the corner creepy it is a bit
weird yeah but it sort of it works for
him yeah I suppose I just I just think
it's very odd and so you can't and what
else do you collect you can see what I
try and collect weird sort of
memorabilia you know I bought for a
ridiculous amount of money I once bought
Winston Churchill's cigar ash so I have
a little cigar stub with Winston
Churchill's ash after I just imagined
him in the war rooms that you know in
after some amazing battle in World War
two just smoking the cigar and then
stopping it out and I've got I've got
that and saying something it's gonna buy
there I really bought JFK's underpants
once why yes they reversible who's
selling somebody sold them in London
suburbs or Christie's anyway they went
for 3,000 pounds and I thought what an
amazingly good bit of Valium and they
got imagine coming to a party and he'd
go to the restroom and there are
President Kennedy's boxer shorts daring
a
wouldn't that inspire you to do
something you can't just use the
bathroom and go of course it was Simon
Cowell's bathroom I wouldn't be able to
see anything I mean you know what I have
one one of the regrets in my life is I
went to a rock-and-roll option once this
is years ago and I was busy shooting a
remote piece and they put up Elvis
Presley's for option Elvis Presley's
library card from Humes high school see
that's great
I and I was busy and it was going it was
no one was really bidding on it and
they're like $300 $400 and I'm such a
huge Elvis nut I thought for the rest of
my and and I was busy and then at the
last second I was like yeah and just
then they said we're taking it off the
block this is what it sounded great
souvenir isn't it yeah it would have
been very cool to have history yeah I'm
selling my hair after tonight a lot of
money your hair yeah is it real no it's
final go ahead it's an incredible mainyu
hat I'm actually interviewing Conan for
the first time on my show in a month and
I can't wait to talk about your mane
there's this magnificent Maine you have
you know it's fantastic
when I last time I was in Ireland I was
walking down the street my hair looked
like this and this Irish wise guy who
was about 70 years old came out to me
and said looked up at my hair and said
what do you feed that thing
I came all the way back home to get
insulted